you probably see my i have daughters so
i have pain
i noticed i noticed a bit off the top i
was like that's a good luck
good luck you should little little
snowed in boredom
i ended up getting my nails painted but
yeah have you kind of rediscovered
anything about yourself
in the time that you've spent at home
with your family i think i've learned
relearned how to be a father maybe
yeah sure i think you know there's a lot
of you know time
for being a little introspective and
retrospective
and you know just kind of realizing what
about our careers in general that we
were
taking for granted
i'm wondering what career-wise you you
said that you sort of took for granted
it's always just go go go you get swept
up in those wheels
and you forget how much music meant to
you
when you first started and now that that
is sort of taken away from us a little
bit the live aspect of it anyway
and how therapeutic that is you realize
how much
that means to your life so i think when
we go back out there
it's going to be an emotional experience
but there's one thing matthew and his
band old dominion aren't taking for
granted
they're up for two grammys this year
country song and country duo or group
performance
you're nominated for two that must feel
pretty cool that feels amazing
that was a real surprise to get those
nominations it was
so it came right at the right moment man
we needed we needed that little
boost of confidence